welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanston and on your marks Racers and get
set to go through one of the most
detailed Laden cues I have ever
encountered see what I did there if you
haven't seen my last video I covered all
of the secrets and Easter eggs hidden
throughout Super Nintendo World but had
to make Mario Kart Bowsers challenge its
own video due to the sheer volume of
stuff that's in here so keep your hands
and feet inside the vehicle and enjoy
the ride the queue starts with the
Yoshi's New Island section which we
talked a bit about in the last video we
can tell it specifically based on
Yoshi's New Island not only because of
the unique coins with Yoshi's face on
them seen at the entrance but also
because each area is based on different
levels of the game the giveaways being
the fields of pink flowers the gem
filled caves and the beanstalks among
other things some other fun details to
note are the themed doors which is such
a great way to make a do not enter door
blend into the world some red coins you
can spot in the caves and a couple of
jumping stars that originated in Yoshi's
Island and have been a part of the
series ever since further along you can
also spot a wing and Cloud if you look
up and several different colors of you
she's popping up out of the flowers then
we get to the castle itself which is
packed to the absolute gills with Mario
Kart 8 references the chain links the
spiked gate the Giant Bowser statue the
banners the shields the lamps even the
fake rug all from the Mario Kart 8
Bowser's Castle stage you go through a
hallway with all of the trophies and cup
symbols from the Game ending with a
universal golden cup which is what you
on team Mario are racing against Bowser
and the Koopalings to win on this ride
there's also a letter from Bowser that
has a similar font to Bowser's letter in
super Princess Peach which I thought was
a cool detail next we enter what I will
call Bowser study and oh boy let's jump
it we first see an Airship model and
blueprints on the walls and imagine my
surprise and Delight when I saw the
blueprints were already labeled Galaxy
makes my job easy right no these are the
exact airships from new Super Mario
Brothers Wii U and while ships that kind
of look like it appeared at the
beginning of Galaxy the back propeller
and some other features are missing it's
the Wii U ships man why they gotta Doom
like this moving on and there's an
adorable furnace powered by lava bubbles
complete with a poker Bellows and other
fire stoking tools there's also tons of
books here's the list of the ones I
found I'm not going to say them all out
loud because there are 75 but a few of
my favorites are Cloudy with a Chance of
pain a romantic's guide to falling in
lava party games for friends and enemies
a Mario Party reference Inside Story
Probably referring to the game Bowser's
Inside Story and unthomp yourself which
I'm pretty sure is a parody of the book
unfuck yourself which is actually a book
I've read looking at the books that
Bowser's been studying lately we have
surviving rainbow road which shows a map
of the Mario Kart 8 Rainbow Road Track
the different boosters and a diagram
showing that lack of two will pick you
up if you fall off the map a book
breaking down the physics of shells you
can throw and brute force a guide to
solving every problem which offers
chapters like ask the experts avoid
arguments never admit fault startup
friendly never say you're sorry direct
orders and are you in charge along with
the inspirational quote surround
yourself with people who obey you
without Quest question thank you Bowser
in this room we also have a crystal ball
perhaps booze Crystal Ball from Mario
Party 4 seeing as there are lots of
booze featured throughout the room a
throne that's kind of similar to
Bowser's throne in Paper Mario Color
Splash with Peach's portrait on it and a
cardboard diorama of a karting track
that teases some of the upcoming
attractions which actually has a Mario
Galaxy reference in the mobile above it
that planet is known as the Gateway
Galaxy and it's the very first place you
land in Super Mario Galaxy to start off
the game this room is so packed there's
even stuff under the table not super
important stuff but it does really make
this place feel lived in if we head over
to a nearby work table we can see it via
Post-its that Bowser has lunch with Iggy
and Roy at noon on Tuesday a feeding
schedule for I assume a piranha plant
and a shopping list that includes
potting soil plant food bandages and
burn cream I love that it includes
bandages and burn cream because it
evokes this great mental image of Bowser
constantly being chopped by piranha
plants or burned by the bomb explosions
considering the blueprint next to the
work table stresses that a short Wick
cannot be used with the bombs though
maybe the fact that he's still working
on the bombs is foreshadowing because
the map on the wall above the work table
lays out which enemies will appear where
in the upcoming course and the only one
that doesn't actually show up in the
area it's supposed to is the bomb moving
along there's a board labeled Today's
starting grid which shows where all the
racers including the two carts that you
and the other group write in should be
lining up at the starting line it's not
quite consistent with the actual race
one example being that the board shows
Daisy and then toad when on the ride
it's towed and then Peach this is Daisy
Erasure after this you head through door
straight out of Bowser's Castle in New
Super Mario Brothers Wii next you enter
an enemy assembly room where Mecca
Koopas the bombs and bullet bills are
being made this drum gives me big Mega
Mecca Koopa swing and stomp from Mario
Party 10 Vibes mixed with the bubon
Factory from Mario Party 9. some fun
details in this room are the hot coals
suspended from the ceiling little Koopa
Footprints leading away from some
spilled oil a chalkboard reviewing the
mechanics of pow blocks and bombs a
production tracker of how many of each
enemy were made that day and hand print
scanners for Bowser and Bowser Jr at the
door you then get to see the Mario Kart
TV or mktv production room mktv is the
fictional broadcasting system in Mario
Kart 8 and is heavily featured in the
first course Mario Kart Stadium and can
be seen throughout other courses too and
this room is decked out in TV production
stuff around the room you can see
cameras soundboards wires storage boxes
apple boxes is a library of tapes lights
even the screens actually show
legitimate test cards that would have
been used in TV broadcasting Studios
throughout the years test cards are
television test signals that were
broadcast to allow for adjustments of
picture quality at the beginning of TV
broadcasting there were actually
physical cards but eventually evolved
into digital cards that allow for things
like color correction alignment and
calibration one of the test cards that
they've obviously Mario fight a bit is
called the Indian Head test pattern and
was introduced in 1939. the different
symbols and lines allowed broadcast
Engineers to adjust framing perspective
frequency response and brightness and
contrast among other things two of the
others shown are two of the more popular
test cards today the Philips pm5644 test
pattern commonly known as the Phillips
pattern and the Ebu color bars the
Phillips pattern provides reference
levels of black white and color
saturation in order to set a receiver
and the Ebu color bars are used to make
sure that there hasn't been an
alteration in color or luminance and
transmission can adjust accordingly if
there has been and that's your TV lesson
from a complete non-expert for the day
but those aren't the only things on the
screens they also show Racers carts
different courses from Mario Kart 8 and
mktv truck that shows up in game in 3DS
toad circuit and Wii Coconut Mall level
a side view of Mario Luigi Peach and
Toad driving by that I believe is an
homage to The Opening screen of the SNES
Mario Kart and most prominently the head
operator of mktv lakitu lakitu appeared
in the first Mario Kart game holding a
starting light that cued Racers but it
wasn't until Super Mario 64 that he got
his start as a camera operator and he
and now his team have been going strong
ever since on another board in the room
you can also see quote unquote live
footage from several Mario Kart courses
the monitor show Bowser's Castle n64's
Rainbow Road Yoshi Valley Rumble volcano
Cloud top Cruise shy guy falls Melody
Motorway which was formerly Music Park
dolphin Shoals swamp ruins Game Boy
advances Mario circuit Twisted mansion
and thwam Bruins again some of the other
cheeky references they snuck in here are
the various tires around the room that
are the Cyber slick standard and hot
monster tires from the game and the
super horn that's between a couple of
the TVs which is an item in the game
that emits a Shockwave around you when
used continuing my obsession with doors
the doors to leave this room are
straight out of Mario Kart 8's Bowser's
Castle so we've made it to the racers
prep room in this room you can see
various racing suits that are actually
the me racing suits that you get from
using amiibos they match all the
characters you can get power bands for
except Daisy snubbed again they also
each have items at their station that
fit the characters they're representing
Luigi has the Poltergust 5000 fun facts
the Poltergeist 4000 was a cart that
debuted in Mario Kart DS Peach has her
parasol that looks closest to her Super
Smash Brothers one Mario has Tanooki
Suit and his Plumbing toolbox and belt
Yoshi has some Yoshi eggs and Toad has a
mushroom and a gift box from the Toad
Houses in this room we can also see the
sponsors for this race which are again
also featured in Mario Kart 8. in this
in the Next Room there are
advertisements for Galaxy Air Roy smooth
sounds Bowser oil mushroom piston
engines Bullet Bill speed trial Mario
Motors Lemmy's Tire Service Undead
Motors and fuzzy battery and the
employees have patches that also
advertise one-up fuel bobom plugs and
green shell taxi next you transition
through a room where the assembly line
continues and has arrows that look like
a mixture of Mario Party 7's Bowser's
Enchanted Inferno and Mario Party 9's
bubon Factory and the banners of each of
the Koopalings before finally Landing in
the load up station to get into your
cart but wait look up into your left and
right to see Mario Luigi's standard
carts and then admire your card which we
can tell from the front and the boosters
in the back is also styled after the
Mario Kart 8 standard cart now for the
ride itself sensibly you start the race
coming out of Bowser's Castle which you
can tell because of the starting line
that matches the games and the Gateway
out you can see what looks to be royal
Raceway judging from Peach's castle the
hot air balloons and the cherry blossom
trees before you're cut off and have to
detour through more of Bowser's traps
also from the game before entering
piranha plant slide you can tell this is
the beginning of the piranha plant slide
course due to the Castle Towers made of
brown stone and giant pipes everywhere
you pass by a view of the Game Boy
advance's Mario circuit before narrowly
avoiding a wave of fuzzies which is
referencing fuzzy timeline a level in
Super Mario 3D World where you have to
escape a rising tide of fuzzies you then
go into a pipe that brings you into the
sewers of piranha plant slide and then
into dolphin Shoals where I face my
worst nightmare a giant eel coming at me
there is a beautiful transition into the
underwater section of the Twisted
Mansion course which also features fish
bones which flawlessly leads into the
above water section of Twisted mansion
with a twisted hallways swinging
chandeliers libraries and booze this
shifts into a gallery of sorts with
paintings that give nod to other Mario
Kart courses we then experience some
Gusty breezes and see Bowser's airships
coming in in a cloud top Cruise section
and get a quick second of Grumble
Volcano before facing off against the
Giant lava-filled Bowser Monument from
Bowser's Castle then we get to my
personal favorite part of the ride as
you cruise down the N64 version of
rainbow road before flying through the
sky and finally ending the race having
circled back to the entrance of Bowser's
Castle and you lost just kidding maybe I
don't know hopefully you won I know I
did and that's my friends is the
entirety of Mario Kart Bowser's
challenge I highly recommend going on
the ride if you can it's a super fun
time and now you can appreciate all the
little details that went into it don't
forget to watch my other video on the
Easter eggs in the rest of the park and
until next time you can follow me on
Twitter at it's annavanston and follow
And subscribe to new rockstars at new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love goodbye
[Music]